If you were stuck in a disaster zone
where the entire country is
sinking into the ground, what would you do
when help is nowhere to be found?
You'll have to do
the most savage things to stay alive.
I'm here to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to be.
The deadly earthquakes
in Japan sinks 2020.
This whole city is about to be destroyed.
Mutoh here is training
to be a star athlete
with a group of other wannabe hopefuls.
While listening to their coach,
they noticed something wrong.
The ground beneath them starts to shake,
and that's when they realize
that a small earthquake
has just hit their city.
But what they don't realize
is that this is the beginning of something
much more terrifying.
The athletes are getting ready to go home
when suddenly everyone receives
a text on their phone telling them
that another earthquake is coming.
And this time, it's
going to be much worse.
Okay, first things first.
You get a warning about an earthquake
on your phone, which means you better
bunker down under some tables
or find something strong to hide under
or in a locker room,
which doesn't give me any confidence that
we're making it out of here in one piece.
Lockers are big and heavy,
and if they fall on top of us were dead.
Realistically, we don't have much time.
And we already felt a minor earthquake,
which means I would leave this room
immediately, find some cover
in the nearest available room or a desk
big enough to hide my handsome self under
the most important thing in an earthquake
is to keep your head covered while losing
your limbs is in an ideal scenario.
It's better than being dead.
Either way, they shouldn't
have headed back to their locker rooms
as soon as they did.
This will cost them everything.
But, you know, it won't cost you
everything. Raid shadow legends.
This game will literally teach you
how to avoid the worst of the worst.
With their global PvP
and absolutely massive PvP boss battles
and over 600 championships, I might add
into Larry, we've got two kinds of us.
We have the normal run of the mill
high elves. They're kind of boring.
You should go with the Serov
elves, the dark elves.
There's all and cool.
The dark elves seven hundred years ago
got tempted by Zeroth,
who tempted them with art and philosophy,
but the arbiter begged them to stop.
But they were too cool for her,
resulting in war that the elves won.
But now, without a never ending back and
forth power struggle lasting centuries.
They're like a legion of evil
assassins and warlocks.
Am I go to stud is the dark elf sniper
with her supercool reign of erel skill.
I can slow my enemies down
while I take them out permanently.
You need to use strategy
in order to survive.
And in this game, you can set the strategy
to whatever level you like.
They've got a jam packed
Halloween lineup coming up
that I am so excited for you guys.
It is so freaking cool.
From major tournaments
to special fragments
that'll even get you some brand
freakin new legendary champions.
Click the link in the description or scan
my QR code so you'll get the epic hero.
Chinchorro, along with 200 cans.
Silver won XP boost one
energy rival and one ancient shard.
So you can summon an awesome champion
as soon as you enter the game.
The rewards will only be available for
the next 30 days and only for new players.
You can find me in-game
under aname can be.
And if you're fast enough,
maybe you can join my clan.
Click the link in the description
and I'll see you in-game.
Thank you, Ryan,
for sponsoring this video.
Now back to the story.
And that's when all hell breaks loose.
The entire room begins to violently shake
and everything starts to fall apart.
Stunned by the earthquake,
Muerto wakes up to a deadly surprise.
All of her fellow classmates
have been brutally crushed,
and she's the only one still alive.
Broken skulls and intestines
are everywhere in shock.
She runs away from the carnage
that just ensued.
But that's not all.
The whole city is being completely
destroyed by the massive earthquake.
Buildings are falling,
planes are crashing, and thousands
upon thousands of people are already dead.
Later on, Mutoh makes it
out of the stadium
and into the outskirts of the city with
no way to contact her friends or family.
She's lost and has nowhere to go.
Holy moly, guacamole.
Now, I know that they were only
a few feet away in their locker rooms
when shit hit the fan a second time.
But honestly, all these tragic accidents
could have been avoided
if they just applied existing knowledge
about earthquakes to begin with.
This is Japan, after all, a country
well-prepared for the 2000
plus earthquakes
they have per year. Yeah, per year.
If that is the case, then
these people should have been
highly educated for disaster scenarios.
The Japanese school curriculum prepares
citizens from birth to act
in an orderly manner
when these situations happen.
Getting caught off guard
by the initial rumblings of an earthquake
can happen, but they should have waited
before heading inside to the locker rooms
as they were already in
one of the safest spots.
They could have been an open
air stadium by design.
These stadiums would have allowed people
to huddle to its center away
from any falling buildings or objects.
Also, they should have waited longer
before heading inside due to aftershocks.
And these can occur up to an hour
after the initial rumblings.
It's not like they had
anywhere better to be.
Tokyo's buildings
themselves are made to withstand
nine point zero earthquakes and above.
So it's unlikely
in this instance that this stadium
would have collapsed from the inside.
And speaking of those locker rooms
from within that locker room
should have been bolted down to begin
with. This is common practice
with many buildings
and within people's homes in Japan.
To prevent this sort of thing
from happening, the school
definitely screwed up on this one.
While it might seem cold
blooded, Mutoh here ditching her
classmates was the right call.
Let's be honest,
she's no medically trained professional.
And did you see that horror show?
There were more dead
teenagers than a slasher movie.
The chance of more rubble falling from
the ceiling is pretty dang high.
So if it were me, I would sprint
like Sonic on speed and hightail it
right out of that locker room
and find someone better equipped
to take care of the situation.
This ain't no Wonder Woman film people.
This is real life.
Sort of on the off chance
the Internet was down,
Mutoh could still have sent
or received a recorded message
to her family using Japan's A.
Disaster Message Board Service,
which is an analog messaging service
in Japan, where people can leave
recording messages
for other people
to check around the world.
This could also give her the ability
to check for any incoming messages left
by her family members,
assuming they're still alive.
Suddenly, Mutoh notices
fluorescent lights on top of a nearby hill
right beneath the Shinto shrine,
realizing the lights are
the same ones her dad likes.
She rushes to the top
and finally reunites with her dad.
And that's when one of her fellow athletes
shows up along with her little
injured brother Go.
The mom joins in on the surprise,
reuniting the whole family
with everything going back to normal.
Suddenly, a mangled body drops
from the tree and people
start falling from the sky.
And that's when they noticed a helicopter
instantly crashed into the city center.
However, this is only the beginning.
Nearly everyone here is going to die,
and no one is safe
from the deadly earthquakes.
If there was an Olympic competition
for the scariest freaking country on earth
right now, then Japan would have had
the fifty ninth medal to their collection,
because this is insanity.
We have enough problems
dealing with earthquakes and tsunamis,
and now we have to fend off
falling corpses to talk about unsanitary.
If they reached terminal velocity,
then we're looking at 190 kilometers
per hour, solid objects
crashing down on us.
And I'm sorry, not even Mary Poppins
umbrella could save our asses.
I would look to hide under the tree
line right there,
as this could have been our best offense
to wait out the human rainstorm.
Mutoh got really lucky realizing
where her dad would be, but in reality,
they should have already had a designated
made up points for situations
like this outside their houses
for after earthquakes
and outside their neighborhood
for bigger earthquake disasters.
And once again, two thousand
plus earthquakes a year people.
Two thousand plus,
you'd think they'd have known better.
The dad pleaded smart
with that emergency kit. He was rocking.
And once again, he could have told you
that having an emergency disaster kit
with important provisions
like food and first aid
should have already
been prepared in advance.
At least one of them
was thinking with their heads,
spending their first day on the hill.
The group wakes up to bad news.
The water has risen above sea level
and their chances of surviving
are getting smaller by the day.
Checking the Internets,
everyone begins to realize
that the whole of Japan
is being demolished.
The whole island of Okinawa has sunk
due to the rising sea levels,
and the rest of Japan is soon to follow
with no other options.
The father gathers everyone together
and they head through the town
to find somewhere safer.
Stuck at a crossroads.
They have two options go westwards towards
Okinawa or head east towards Ibaraki.
One of the men tells the group
that he has a distribution
center full of food and resources
needed for survival.
However, goes online.
Friend from Estonia here takes him and
says that going west is the safer option.
So the family decides to listen to a kid
from halfway across the world
and head west while the rest of the group
decides to head east. Hold on.
We need to pump the brakes a little bit,
because what our options are either head
west in the direction
of a place that doesn't
even exist anymore or head east,
where some guy has a distribution center
full of food and shelter
and the family wants to go west.
This is one of those instances
where I feel the need to comment politely
to our anime groups, fictional intellect.
Why are you all so stupid?
This is the perfect example of human
error at its finest.
Aside from the dads med kit,
they have no provisions, no food.
They barely have any water.
And yet they're willing
to trust a friend of a child
who's not even in the same country
as them right now. Idiot.
We don't know what's going on.
So we need to conserve
what battery have left and goes online.
Social life can wait. Now both moves on
where to go are a gamble.
So we should apply
a little common sense here.
The direction heading down to Okinawa
has lower lying land than the east
or even central Japan,
which has on average
the highest points of elevation
compared to the rest of Japan.
If the land is sinking, which it is,
it wouldn't make sense to head
to lower lying land.
Also heading directly
to the epicenter of the earthquake
is where most of the damage
will have taken place,
as this is where the hypocenter or
focus of the earthquake would have begun.
Which means stuff there,
including buildings and resources,
will be worse off than anywhere else.
It also wouldn't be a bad idea
to get familiarized with this group
and figure out what skill sets they have
were much better in a group than solo.
And this is a chance
to find out what everybody is good at.
Are any of them hunters
or nurses? Doctors?
This is the time
to get friendly with everybody.
And if all goes to hell,
then I'd see if I could
convince the second group
to simply head west instead.
As this way I could have the distribution
center to myself. What can I say?
I need it more on the way there.
We need to look for weaponry as people
tend to have a bad habit of doing
terrible things when pushed to the edge,
which may just happen very.
Walking on the highway, Mutoh
notices to old people in need worried
for their safety.
She decides to give them the family's
last remaining water bottle.
What a nice girl.
Worried about being at sea level,
the family heads for the mountains.
Suddenly they find a nearby creek
full of fresh drinking water.
This is a gold mine.
This right here is money. Since Mutoh
decided to give away all our water,
which is priceless at the moment.
This is the best thing
we've seen in a while,
which is why we can't afford
to let this go to waste.
If I was them, I would stay here
pretty much as long as they could,
or at least for a
longer time than they did.
We have replenishing water and we could,
in theory, forage for various nuts
and berries and mounting crap
that is native to Japan, such as butter,
burr, ostrich fern, flowering, rapeseed,
spring chrysanthemum, among other things.
Earthquakes don't last forever.
And if they are this far away
from everything and low on supplies,
I would seriously consider staying here
for at least a night or two until they
have more information to work with.
Consider it a bonus
that they are high up and away
from tall structures later that day.
The family heads past ruined towns
and deserted areas, but
luckily they managed to find
and catch some pork grub before the night.
Not knowing that one of them
is going to die the very next day.
That morning, the group finds a sign
that says there are Japanese yams
in the nearby area.
The father decides to go digging,
so they have dinner for the coming night.
That's when Mutoh notices
something very sinister.
They've completely ignored
one of the signs. And guess what it says?
Unexploded mines could be buried here.
Suddenly, the father makes one last dig
and a mine explodes right on the spot,
killing him instantly and raising
the family of a father forever.
The group decides
to keep on heading west while they cope
with the crazy shit that just happened.
Luckily for them, a cheeky trucker
comes by and lets them hitch a ride.
But this ride isn't for free.
Stopping at a gas station.
The athlete here goes to wash her hands
when suddenly the trucker comes by
and tries to attack
her mom, comes from behind
and manages to take him out
using his truck.
They make their way as far as possible
before it runs out of gas.
First off, this is why you always read
the signs of a gated fence, idiots
not reading clear danger
warning signs and digging around places
known for a lot of buried explosives.
Frankly, Pops here was just asking for it,
which is also kind of weird
since he, out of all of them,
seemed to be the most capable.
And let's talk about that.
A nutjob thirsty driver for a sec.
I know you got to pay the troll
for a toll, but this is insanity.
He is a case example of why
I mentioned weaponry earlier, folks.
And as much as we'd like to imagine
that people in times of crisis
will come together
for the good of humanity.
Honestly, that is not a guarantee.
People know that in cases like this, the
daily rules of life don't always apply.
And unfortunately,
dealing with people who take advantage of
this is more common than we think.
The longer the world goes to hell,
the more and more people
will start to lose it.
And not everybody has good intentions.
I'm sorry to say.
This is also why I mentioned
traveling in groups and why athletes
girl got lucky thanks to mum and her tag
teaming our thirsty friend over here.
Find a group if you can,
and for God's sake, pack
some form of self-defense as Mother Nature
won't always be your only enemy.
The next day, the group keeps going on
foot, seeing Mount Fuji in the distance.
Mutoh, an athlete, decide to take
a breather and go for a pee down the hill.
But this move is going to cost them.
Suddenly the athlete
collapses on the ground,
and that's when a mysterious man
from the sky warns Mutal
to not go any further or else she'll die.
It turns out that toxic gas is surrounding
the area below the hill.
The athletes went too far
in, which caused her to suffocate
and die on the spot.
The mysterious man
introduces himself as Kite, a
YouTuber that flies around in a promoter
taking videos of the Japanese landscape.
He offers to take one person with him
on his promoter, but everyone refuses.
Because of this, he changes his mind
and decides to join the group,
leaving his promoter behind like an idiot.
This just made everything
a lot more complicated.
She fell harder than a sack of potatoes,
and without warning,
unless she had an aneurysm
or a blood clot somewhere,
this could only be from some outside
force, like a type of gas.
We don't know for sure,
but I'm willing to bet.
What Just cause this was high
levels of methane gas, which is a gas
you can't see or even smell,
and one that is produced naturally
from the decay of natural material
such as plants and animals,
which is also found beneath the sea bed.
The disruption of the tectonic plates
may mean that this gas
could have seeped up
and is now running
wild in deadly high amounts.
A little by itself
is not the worst thing I know.
I've tried it. It's fun to smoke it,
but too much can result in immediate
loss of consciousness.
And judging by how quickly our friend
passed out, I'm certain it's methane gas.
While technically we could have saved her,
Mutoh made the right move.
Backing away in time, if anything, mom
should have backed up to save her.
But let's be real.
What could she have done?
And if we're running low on food and
water, that might not be the worst thing.
She lived a good life.
Maybe what I would be concerned with
is watching for wind direction,
because now if there's toxic gas around,
then we need to try and position ourselves
upwind rather than downwind, if possible.
Now, I don't know for the life of me
why they left behind that promotor.
That thing is so useful now.
Unless we know anything about
paramotoring, we couldn't have done much.
Ourselves and this thing
ain't like riding no damn bike.
If you fall off on a promoter,
well in the air you might die.
But we could have used Kite as a means
to get some aerial reconnaissance,
at least while we still had
some fuel to burn.
It's not like he couldn't have carried
the damn thing whilst
not in use, as promoters are known
for the lightweight engines
finding a supermarket.
The group scours
the place for any edible goods
and useful items
when they suddenly
get alerted by a toy robot.
That's when Aerostar
start firing off from every direction,
giving them the Hawkeye special,
and then the group splits up
to find a cover.
In the midst of the chaos,
go almost gets fatally shot by an arrow.
That's when an odd looking grab bag
comes down from the upper floor
to apologize and offers
the group's shelter
while they wait out the stormy weather.
The next day, the group gets ready
to say their goodbyes.
Suddenly, another earthquake hits
and both the group and grandpa are forced
to evacuate the area in his pickup truck.
The Grandpa suggests
they go to a place called Shan City,
a shelter for those who've been affected
by the disaster later that night.
The group sets up camp and watches
a national report from the prime minister.
The group's plans are interrupted
by a landslide, meaning they need to take
another route on the way.
They pick up a foreign hitchhiker
and finally make it to Shan City.
The city welcomes them with open arms
and offers the group food
and shelter free of charge.
Shan City boss man introduces
the gang to their little town.
But while the city might seem friendly,
they're hiding a much darker secret
than no one realizes.
Meanwhile, Kite here sneaks out to go
visit grandpa, who's sleeping in his car.
He slips him some morphine
for his drug addiction,
but grandpa here is looking for something
much more sinister.
And everyone here is going to be shocked.
The next day, the group checks out
a ceremony by mother,
the leader of the city.
She has the ability to talk
to dead people and communicate
to loved ones for their final words.
Whether good or bad, all she needs
is a keepsake from the person who died.
However, she only performs this ritual
three times a day.
Kite tries to see just how legit mother
is by handing her glasses guys
glasses, claiming
it was athlete girls who died from
the methane gas touching the glasses.
Mother here decides to throw them a bone
and tell him that
the object says it was me
who said, take a break,
don't you worry about it.
These are the same words athlete
girl said a few days earlier.
And now everyone is shocked to find out
their mother might be legt after all.
Meanwhile, everyone has settled
into the city, working various jobs
and becoming members of the community.
Mutoh here has been assigned
as a caretaker for a disabled man.
They can talk and can barely move.
However, he shows something very strange
by twitching his thumb
and flickering his eyes
right before a minor earthquake hits.
While Mutoh might not realize
that this disabled man
is going to be very important
in the near future, now, this cult
may be friendly, but I don't trust anybody
who dresses in full weight.
This place looks safe for now,
and we've got food and a place to rest
after the day we've had.
I wouldn't be complacent just yet.
Delayed aftershocks can be greater
than the initial main shock,
with a five percent chance
of this happening
within a week of the initial rumblings.
Earthquake sizes are largely
related to the length of the fault line
upon which the country sits.
The longer the fault line,
the larger the earthquake.
And despite Japan being right
on top of the Johnny Cash ring of fire,
there is no known fault line long enough
to generate a magnitude 10 earthquake.
However, what we've seen proves
something is strange,
which is why I would still be on alert
and trying to steal food and water
from the kitchen during after hours.
I know, I know this white too loving.
It seems safe, but
we cannot let our guard down
and be ready to move out
at a moment's notice.
Later that night, Mutoh goes to a dance
festival held in the village center.
It turns out that Kite and Glasses guy
are there as well,
and they're killing it on the booth
in the early hours of the morning,
grab a hair, manages
to break into the castle, kill two people
and steal mother's kid and drive out.
What a crazy old man.
He thinks their mother's
kid is his own family
because he is high as a kite
and a tiny bit delusional.
However, while attempting to escape
the city, he crashes his truck directly
on the gates, stopping him in his tracks,
locked up for his actions.
Mother and her team analyzed Grandpa's
condition from the security camera.
They believe his morphine
withdrawals are responsible
for his crazy antics, but they decide
to leave as punishment for later Mutoh.
Here is looking after the disabled man.
She notices that his constant twitches
and blinking might be a sign that he's
speaking in Morse code,
trying to communicate with the man.
She uses a Morse code app on her phone
to decipher what he's trying to say.
Suddenly she realizes that he's trying
to say that a big earthquake is coming
and that this area is dangerous.
After communicating with him,
she realizes that the disabled man is Mr.
Onodera, a famous geologist that predicted
Japan would sink right before it happened.
During the news, Mutoh here rushes
to tell mom about what she's just heard.
The two announce what's going to happen
during the town festival later that night,
but no one believes them.
Suddenly a fire erupts in the village
and the ground starts
to break open and part of the town's
statue breaks off directly onto go.
But the chef covers
go from the giant debris,
sacrificing himself in the process,
realizing the danger.
Mother orders everyone to evacuate
immediately in the midst of the chaos.
Kite here manages
to sneak into Grampa's prison cell.
Suddenly Buzz cut
here comes down to warn them of
what's just happened
and tells them to leave the city now.
However, grandpa
still wants to find the child
and decides to head upstairs
to find him. Buzz Cut finds.
Other wounded from a gunfight
as members are going crazy,
trying to steal all their city gold.
Mother then tells them that
they must find her son before they leave.
Finally, they reached
the top of the castle,
and for the first time in 10 years,
the child speaks.
Suddenly, a piece of rubble crashes
down from the roof, killing him instantly.
Grampa Incyte arrive soon after
and explains that his grandchild died
in a landslide and he wanted to believe
that he was the same kid reincarnated.
But his come to terms with the accident,
getting ready to leave
the rest of the group hop in the truck .
However, the hitchhiker
decides to stay back,
telling them he belongs in Shan City
and is willing to die.
Meanwhile, Grandpa tells
Kai to leave him behind in the castle,
telling him that his days are numbered.
The entire building collapses
as the remaining survivors head elsewhere
under a reign of gunfire and chaos.
OK, we don't have time
to mess around right now.
Didn't I say something was up?
If we prepared for this earlier,
we could have filled the truck
with provisions like food and water
and left a better off than Mutoh
and her group did.
As of now, they have five people
and no supplies whatsoever
from the fall of that statue.
Now you get why we couldn't
have stayed in the town to begin with.
One of the major problems
during earthquakes
is the liquefaction of the earth's soil,
which happens when the strength
and stiffness of soil is reduced
by the shaking of an earthquake.
Turning the ground into literal liquid,
we've stumbled upon
something much more important.
The famous paralyzed geologist.
He seems to know all about what's going on
and is the only person we can rely on
for accurate information.
So in retrospect, it's not a bad trade.
And thanks to Mutoh,
we found a way to talk to him.
I would use this time
whilst driving away to find out
everything we can know about what he knows
while he is extremely valuable.
He is also a serious burden.
This is why I'd get everyone
except the mom driving the car to help
find out everything that he knows.
This way, we can soon ditch him
and not worry about it. The next day,
the group heads for the nearest port
to board the evacuating ships.
There can only be 1000 people per ship,
and the whole country
is racing to the ports.
Time is running out, reaching the port.
The group is forced to go on foot.
The line for the ship
is absolutely massive
and thousands upon thousands of people
are being rejected on the spot.
Suddenly, Mr Onodera tells the group
that another earthquake is coming.
But what they don't realize
is that this earthquake is going to be
the deadliest of them all lining up.
Mutoh here notices one of her coaches
waiting in line alongside her.
Her coach mentions that the government
has given special treatment
to young people with promising abilities,
meaning Mutoh here has a free ticket
to board the ship saying goodbye.
She hugs her mom and notices
something strange around her waist,
but ignores it for now,
since no one else was given a ticket.
She boards the ship,
but at the last minute
realizes that the fanny pack
her mom was carrying is actually part
of a ventricular assist device,
meaning she recently had heart surgery
causing Mutoh to leave the ship
and rejoin her family.
And that's when all hell breaks loose.
Mount Fuji suddenly erupts,
forcing the group back into the truck
and destroying the terrain around them.
The group manages to find another port,
sending people to safety.
However, this time
it turns out they're only letting people
that are purely Japanese
aboard their boat.
Meaning Mutoh and her happy family
aren't allowed on board.
Luckily for them, a nice old guy
lets them board his boat, setting sail.
They notice a boat
near them explode in the distance.
Suddenly shrapnel starts flying
from every direction and pierces the boat.
The nice old guy whips out a lifeboat,
but only Mutohko and himself managed
to make it inside while the original boat
gets absolutely destroyed.
Separating them from their mother later
that night, the remaining survivors reach
something strange in the water.
It's a high rise building, meaning
the whole of Japan has officially sunk.
All right. This is not looking good.
We've been sitting here
for what seems like ages
and we can't tell how much time has passed
because the sky is blocked
by ash and smoke.
This also means that it's
nearly impossible
for anyone flying overhead to see us.
This group got extremely lucky and likely
wouldn't have made it
in any other scenario.
We can't use the sun's reflection
through a piece of mirror or our phone
screens to alert any nearby planes
or ships, nor from the looks of things.
Can we use any non-porous materials
like a raincoat to catch and store
drinkable rainwater based on
what's Mutoh told us?
Volcanic ash has polluted the air,
meaning any rainwater
we collect will be unsafe to drink.
However, desperate times
call for desperate measures.
So I would carefully consume
small amounts of collected ash water,
but only as a last resort,
since we would be stranded here
for a long time.
Small amounts of ash taken
through the water in limited quantities
could present a low risk of toxicity.
In this situation, we have little choice
the longer we remain stranded.
Mutoh Engo here missed out on
a big opportunity to take a break
on top of the sunken building.
They could have used that place as a base
whilst they waited out the rescue,
as this would have also ensured
that they don't get pushed
further out into sea
or be at the mercy of any rogue waves.
And while this might sound
counterproductive,
instead of eating the chocolate bar,
they should have fought off their hunger
and used it as bait to catch fish.
Yes, you heard me right.
According to our friend, a famous
survivalist, Michael Horwath, in his book,
The Sea Survival Manual,
fish are attracted to vessels and boats.
This means if Mutoh had any jewelry on her
or if she used pieces of her phone,
she could have used this as a makeshift
lure to attract fish to her area.
And she could have used her
shoelaces or unravel sock
threads to serve as a fishing line.
After a few days at sea, the group starts
to get sick and weak suddenly.
During that night, Mutoh here
wakes up and notices the old guy
hunched over the tent wall
with some nice seagulls, viciously
attacking him, shooing them away.
She looks over and notices
something extremely horrifying.
The man has been dead for hours
and the seagulls have peeled his skin
from flesh. Suddenly a shark
comes out of nowhere and takes them away.
Mutoh here zips the tent up
and the to wait until help arrives.
After a few days out on sea,
Mom and glasses guy here
finally find the kids
before they starve to death.
Glasses guy shows them
coordinates left by Mr.
Onodera and go here figures out that
they must be located east of Hiroshima
using a self-made compass.
They figure out exactly
where the closest shore is and head off.
A stranded motorboat is
then spotted out of the blue,
but unlucky for them, it's stuck
volunteering to fix the issue.
Mom here dives in and tries
to dislodge the rope.
She manages to dislodge it successfully,
but before she makes it to the surface,
she drowns before anything can be done.
OK, mom took one for the team here.
And this is exactly why it's good
to have people with different skill sets
take turns, risking their lives this way.
They can get the group out of sticky
situations while we sit back and relax.
And since the motor is placed in the back,
I'm willing to take a guess
that the boat had a V drive inboard system
rather than a direct drive system,
which would have had
the motor placed
in the middle of the boat.
This means that this is no easy feat.
But someone could have tried
reversing the boat
just slightly enough
to loosen the tension on the rope,
which would have made it easier to help
mom pull out the rope,
giving her a few precious extra seconds
to swim back to the surface.
If this sounds too complicated,
then it probably is.
Mom here is a pro swimmer,
but her glory days might be behind her.
She should have been able
to hold her breath for much longer
and known that swimming rapidly,
upwards from deep water to the surface
would cause her to pass out.
She could have easily
survived the situation
by taking a moment to physically
and mentally prepare her body to withstand
the underwater pressure
by inhaling and exhaling
slowly from deep within her diaphragm.
We can read the lungs of low quality air,
preparing for two intake excess oxygen
to be stored within the blood cells.
Applying this technique for a few minutes
would have ultimately helped her increase
the amount of time she could have held her
breath. While it might seem difficult.
She only needed a few more seconds
and she would have made it
back to the boat safe and sound.
Sometime later, a Japanese
tank approaches them.
Suddenly, Kite appears
and invites them in with Mr.
Onodera, also chilling with him as well.
After a turbulent trip,
they finally make it to land
and find a nearby hot spring
after a well deserved break.
Kite here takes the group
to the only place in Japan
that can withstand a natural disaster.
He knows of a place with secret archives
that might hold the information to be able
to save the entire country
from any further damage.
Exploring the island,
they find a secret cave,
but Kite here decides to go it alone
with Onodera walking inside,
they find a secret research room
with the files he was looking for.
It's Kate manages to transfer the files
into a hard drive, a roaring earthquake.
Then Trumbull's once again
hitting the island as the room begins
to fill with water using an oxygen tank.
He and Onodera managed
to swim back to the surface,
but they're not safe just yet.
Strong waves begin to hit the island
and the hard drive
gets swept away in the process.
It's dangerous, but glasses guy here
decides to go fetch the files
after an absolutely epic sprint.
He grabs the data chip
and nearly makes it back to safety.
He tosses the data chip to the gang
right before a massive wave slams
right into him from the side, killing him.
If we think about it for a second,
he was our best bet since he had extensive
experience in track and field.
Mutoh here is also an athlete.
But her leg is injured
and her only other options
were a kid, a YouTuber and a paraplegic,
meaning we don't have many options.
Judging from the rough stone coastline,
that area looks pretty deadly.
Even if this guy was a professional
big wave surfer.
You would have still been dragged into
the stone coastline or the seabed itself.
And there's little chance
of surviving that.
If hourglasses guy, instead of waiting
for a wave to come and go and then run.
I would have begun running as
soon as the waves came crashing into me.
This would have been a little riskier,
but would have given us a whole extra
second, meaning we have 11 seconds,
not 10, to make it back.
And an extra second was all that
this guy needed if he timed it better.
Checking the archives.
They find a ray of hope.
Onodera predicted exactly which areas
would sink, as well as which areas would
rise back up, meaning parts of Japan
will return in coming years.
Using a raft, they find a hot air balloon
floating in the ocean.
Kaita manages to fill
it using a spare oxygen tank,
but the balloon only has room for one.
So Kite here decides to fly away
on his own, leaving the rest for dead
jerk. Checking Mr.
Onodera, his body, they find a working
phone with a working Internet connection.
It turns out the kite use the hot
air balloon to find an Internet signal
alerting their location
to rescue services.
And that's when a helicopter comes
and picks them up, all due to kite.
Now they are safe while looking over
the ravaged Japanese landscape.
Mutoh suddenly passes out
due to the cut on her leg.
She's taken to the hospital
and operated on.
A doctor informs her
that due to the infection on her leg,
she's developed separative osteomyelitis,
a condition which will kill her.
And the only way to stop the infection
from killing her is to amputate her leg.
Eight years later,
Japan has risen once again.
Mutoh here is competing at the 2028
Paralympics with a prosthetic leg,
remembering all that she's lost.
She completes her dream
of being a world class athlete,
marking her legacy in the history books.
And if you want to. Joined
the history books along with Mutoh.
Then I suggest you come on down below.
Let us know what you like,
what you didn't like.
Don't forget to give us a big thumbs up.
And don't forget
to subscribe to our channel.
And also don't forget to check out
our playlist and our tik tok page.